- [Eric] You know they say,
prison was my saving grace.
But then, on the flip side
of that, I look at well,
what part does rehabs play in all of this?
You know, if I don't take
a look at that aspect,
then, people won't understand or realize
how it takes up to 30 attempts
for me to finally get it.
Get it?
So I like to integrate on...
life in rehabs, you know,
life and trying to get
my shit together, life,
and trying to get my life
in some kind of order,
trying to get from chaos
to normalcy, in all the countless
vain attempts in-between.
So,
I like the store it
from, you know, what was-
How it was sold to me, you know,
it was told to me that, you know,
"Hey, look, man, when it gets tough
on the streets, when it gets bad,
you want to check out,
you don't have to take your ass to prison,
you can go to rehab, you know,
it's less stress, you know,
and you got more available to you.
Right?"
I said, "Okay."
So when the seed was planted to me,
it was planted to me, like
I think after my fourth trip
to prison, man, when I came home
and I was- I ended up right
back where I started off at,
in best shape, real fast.
So,
now I liked that rehab as
an adventure, you know,
'cause I'm not going home away from home,
but I'm still on the streets.
I'm still in the environment, you know?
And I never wanted to do a
program close to where live,
I want it to be out.
Like where the quote on
quote where the money was,
because like Santa Monica, West Hollywood,
San Fernando Valley, there's more money.
So for someone like me,
that'd be more opportunity.
Or so I thought.
Not knowing that rehabs have set up,
just like, say, the prison setting,
they only can give you so much.
And first and foremost,
rehabs are a business,
don't get it twisted.
So whatever you don't put
into it, is sit your ass,
don't get up out of it.
And for me, I'd never think,
I'd never forget being
in the first rehab, man.
And it was like 30 of us in
a room. (chuckles lightly)
They said, "Out of 30%
of you, only 3% are going
to make it so out of 30,
that's only 3 of you guys.
So look next, look to your neighbor
because you might not see them again
before this is all over."
So I looked to my left, man.
Excuse me.
I looked to my right and
then, I looked to my left
and I said, "I know they
ain't talking about me."
And lo and behold, I wasn't one
of the 3% men that made it.
Now,
I didn't see,
the importance in that
statement right there.
For the simple fact
that I had no idea what
I was going into rehab.
I had no idea how bad
the disease was on me.
That crack motherfucking cocaine.
I didn't know how bad of a
hold of a grip it had on me.
So, when I went into the first rehab,
I didn't even have all the courage.
I lacked the courage.
I lacked the strength.
Because that shit had a hold of me.
And to be honest with you,
I wasn't even finished
with smoking that crack.
Now, going to rehab, okay.
Going into it.
I was like, "Okay, I need help."
You know, I'm good,
but there's many factors
that could've played a reason in that.
I remember my second,
third, fourth, fifth trip
to rehab, you know.
"Oh, I'm going to do this for my mama."
"This is for my mama."
For all the time, she'd been there for me
and supported me and loved
me and all that bullshit.
Go for her.
Become the compliant client in near.
Do everything I'm supposed to do,
jumped through the motherfucking hoops,
do everything I'm supposed to do.
Get out.
And end up right back up, right
back where I wasn't worse.
Okay, Imma do it this time
for my nephew, Christopher.
'Cause I wasn't there for
his childhood growing up.
So this is for you kid
or Imma do this for my nephew, Isaiah.
Or now, Imma do this for my sister, Tracy,
'cause she always loved the
support of me, her baby brother.
You know what?
Imma do this for Todd.
To show him that I am
somebody, that I am capable.
And at last one, I just blew
up my motherfucking mind.
Oh, this is for God,
who had his hand on me the
whole motherfucking time.
I've been in and out,
back and forth to prison,
off and on that motherfucking crack.
But having his hand over me
and having a grace and mercy.
Oh, this for you, God, I got your...
(imitates high pitch sound)
gear, right?
I went in programs half-heartedly
because truth be told,
how can I go into rehab
and then do a session
on talking or doing a one-on-one
with my counselor and
say, "Straight up, man.
I had a dream that night before man
and wouldn't smoke a ton
of crack cocaine, man."
And damn, they left
this motherfucker to go.
How am I gonna be in a rehab
and tell my counselor that,
on a one-on-one.
How he still had a hold on my ass.
So I didn't want to let me go.
And I wasn't ready for it to let me go.
Guess I wasn't tired, man.
I wasn't to the point, man,
where I just fully surrender.
So I'm gonna put all these excuses,
all these disguises,
all these different ways to maneuver.
You know, instead of just
really doing it for me.
I remember in-between say
the 7th and the 15th rehab.
Every time I go, it's like
boy, Ms. Girl on campus.
Fall in love, get married,
live happily ever after.
It seemed like from the,
back then, when I was going to say,
I was going to rehabs all through the 90s.
So it was like kind of a-
It was cool back then,
to be in rehab, you know,
to have the-
I would remember going out to a rehab
and all the fellows was real
nice and sharp and clean
and had the little rings and
little watch and this and that.
And I had nothing.
So my thing was,
how fast can I accumulate
the outside things
and say I go to a six month program.
Now, I only go, I show up with a trash bag
with a few belongings.
With then, six months, I'll
leave with the nice watch.
Maybe a treat, maybe a ring,
maybe a nice little necklace,
two, three trash bags,
Philippians shirts, all that
stuff that accumulated later.
Now, I think I'm the man.
But I say from the 7th
to about the 20th rehab,
that was my theme.
That was my mode of operation
going to the motherfucker with nothing,
but just with the clothes on my back
and try to leave out with as much as I can
with a truck load full of
stuff that I accumulated.
"Hey, man, you need this."
"Hey, you're going to use that."
"Hey, can I get to."
"Hey."
Hustling, caught myself, firstly,
trying to get back on my feet.
Talking about,
"Oh, I'm trying to get the get back."
Man, please, it wasn't no get back.
I wasn't there to get my shit together.
I was there to accumulate some stuff.
That's all.
I mean, I put forth into the team.
Of course, I had courted to ask the team.
Because every time I'd go
up to the rehab, I meet her.
Oh, she's going to make
everything gone, right?
Oh, yeah, we're going to
do this shit together.
We're going to combine our shits together
and ain't nothing that can take us down.
Shit.
As soon as I get to
the program, I see her.
She's seen me.
She smells.
She wink.
Here we go again, man.
I don't give a fuck about my problem.
I don't have no problems, shit, man.
"Hey girl, what's your name?"
"Hey, how long have you been here?"
"Hey, you want to do something?"
And lo and behold.
It ain't about me, no more being in rehab.
It's about her, her needs, her won'ts.
How can I deal with her?
How can I take care of her?
How can I meet her needs?
How can I-
How can I meet her standards?
While trying to navigate.
"Aww, baby, no, I wasn't
that bad on the streets."
Now, I'm lying.
She don't know nothing about
me, but what I tell her.
So I'm trying to paint this picture
of how I ended up in here,
but I'm not that bad.
Do I look bad, girl?
Oh, hell no.
See, I told you, I wasn't that bad,
as most of them out
there doing that stuff.
Then, I kind of changed the picture.
"Oh, what was your own, baby,
on this, oh, alcohol, marijuana?"
I don't do that, crack stuff.
Cocaine? Nah, shit, not me.
Please, do I look a like a crackhead?
(sighs)
Cold game
that I played in rehab.
Rehabs, over the years off and on.
I went to rehabs, man,
when I was just really
tired of just being tired.
Fucking feet is aching and hurting.
Fucking lips is burnt and swollen,
from the fucking pipe beans,
being like this
and beginning like this in the
end, burns shit up my lips.
my fingers, came over,
flicked the BIC lighter.
What fucking happened?
8, 9, 10 days.
Had a cup of water or a cup
of noodle or nothing, man.
Not even bathed.
That's when I need to rehab.
That's when the doors
are opened up for me.
And then, I have to go into them.
Go to the detox,
go in there for about, four to five days,
sleep in a cocaine coma.
It means as soon as I close my eyes,
I'm not waking up for
three, four, five days.
And then, once I get up
off the cocaine slumber,
and then, I'll still go, "Man,
I'm glad that part is over.
The horror part is over."
Now, when I wanna eat up
every motherfucking thing
and drink up everything.
Like I tried to smoke
up everything (chuckles)
on the streets, man,
and drink a bottle of alcohol, you know.
Just the roles reversed, you know?
So now, I get off the cocaine slumbers.
I'm eating up, I'm gobbling everything.
I'm eating everything I can.
You know, eating up all the cereal,
the milk, the water, all
that kind of stuff, man.
And now, he said,
"Okay, Eric, these are
options we have for you.
We have these programs."
"Hey, man, he has to be co-ed."
Why does it have to be co-ed?
Why does women have to be
a part of the equation?
Because I've been in and out
of prison all these years, man.
I'm not trying to be on the streets, man.
And dealing with a whole
bunch of horn heads.
I did that shit in prison.
I got 19 trips in-between
these 30 rehabs, man.
Fucking want to be on the streets
and just dealing with me and for-
I can do that shit in prison.
On the streets, man,
I want to, like I said before.
I don't want to be around all men.
I'm sorry.
I can't handle, I can't deal with that.
'Cause it makes me feel
like I'm in prison again.
Oh, I had to get the gap.
I just didn't know I was fooling myself.
Yeah, it worked.
Okay, yeah, okay.
Well we go, okay.
Yeah, we got this place called,
this place out here called acting.
Man, I get out there.
It's in the middle of the wilderness.
You got cabins and all
that kind of stuff, man.
You got the gym out there, man.
I'm in heaven, got mass out
there, worked in the kitchen,
became a fitness instructor
up in there, man.
And...
I liked that one so much.
I went five times,
in a row back to back to
back to back to back to back
to motherfucking back.
And all the five times
I was in a relationship
on the campus.
Thinking I'm hip slick and cool.
Thinking I'm doing something.
You know, but all the while I was there
and all the times that I was there,
those five times,
all I did was divert
the attention off of me
and putting it on her
or putting it on the gym
or putting it on the kitchen,
where the fuck else I
was being a service set.
'Cause I wasn't being a service to myself.
I was sipping everything
and everybody outside of me.
So when I wouldn't have to
deal with my mother pregnant,
so I wouldn't have to look at me.
Man, if I had to go all the way back,
from the beginning,
leading up to when I
first got into the rehab.
Man, I wasn't not-
I want to see about this here, man.
Not but my track record.
Man, you better not
show me a real pitcher.
I'll kill you.
You know.
'Cause, man, I did damage, man.
I did harm, man, to
myself and to everybody
that came in contact with me, man.
And I did a lot of robbing.
I did a lot of stealing and
did a lot of stuff, man.
Behind the name of that
crack cocaine, man.
It wasn't the motherfucking thing.
Finding about getting that
money by any means necessary.
Ask somebody.
(respires)
Towards the end of my campaign, man,
of doing this rehab
marathon kind of thing, man,
'cause I was proud of my self on.
I've said,
"Okay, I've been to two
to three different rehabs,
nine times!"
You know, I remember I
was a part of the back
in the days at the Maryland Foundation.
So, I did the fucking
with Reena B, the BME,
the rural palms,
two of them were co-ed,
one was all male.
So I did the co-eds,
like four times a piece.
So I did these two programs, eight times,
eight different times.
Four times in this motherfucking-
Four times in this-
All eight times I was in
a relationship. (claps)
I said, "Let me try the last
one, the all male program,
part of it,
and see what that if that help."
When I go to the all male facility
and ended up climbing down a fire escape.
I think after maybe three days
that I was there 'cause I got tired
of looking out the motherfucking window,
across the street looking at the pipes
at the bus at the fucking
phone booth, do his thing.
He was serving, man, let me go down
and see what this
motherfucking working with.
So, instead of being like the average Joe,
going down the stairs,
then right, man, I climbed up the window
and down a fire escape.
Take my ass across the street cop,
bop my ass back to my room
and to miss the smoke, man.
And once I started, I couldn't stop
and call myself going downstairs
for dinner.
So I started in afternoon,
I think around 10 or 11 in the afternoon
and then, it was at 4:35,
five o'clock,
so five o'clock coming around.
I'm going downstairs, tweaked
out my motherfucking mind,
eyes as big as golf balls.
And he pulled me to the side,
"Hey man, we need to test you."
No, you don't.
I'm dirty, man.
I surrender.
How the fuck you gonna get
loaded and I don't know.
You tell me, your guess is good as mine.
Shit.
You're the counselor,
don't you have the answer?
How the fuck?
I have no idea how I ended
up getting loaded into rehab.
This ain't the first one.
It's probably won't be the last one.
I'm trying to come up with a
viable answer to this bullshit,
'cause I'm really- I have no clue.
On how I'll go to get
some motherfucking helping
and while I'm at the place.
Didn't help.
I ended up getting loaded, man.
Getting the ends to the
means to get loaded.
I don't know how it happens, man.
It seems like something
just takes over my mind.
I'm here one minute.
The next minute I'm at somebody else.
There's some kind of entity takes over
and just has me going out there and...
it's like magic.
I still can't get that trick.
I never understood how
they put the bunny up,
the rabbit out the head.
And I seen it a thousand times.
It's like my experiences in rehab.
I know some shit and
understand some things.
But for the life of me, for me to be in,
in getting some help
and then, become helpless.
I just never got that part of it.
(stomps)
I call on God, please God,
you got to show me something.
You got to do something, man.
You know, and finally, man,
I think towards the 30th trip, man,
my 30th trip.
(exhales)
Going to my-
I'll got to see it, man,
tomorrow, my saving grace man,
'cause rehab was a part
of my saving grace, man.
'Cause if it wasn't for rehab,
I probably would end up dead, man.
A lot quicker than being in prison.
You know, because I have to admit,
even though I was in relationships.
Even though sometimes I
went for other people,
but I always went for the right reasons.
Now in the beginning, I didn't have see-
The grip of cocaine was so strong on me.
I didn't know the power
still had a hold over me,
even while I was in rehab.
And so while I'm in the
state of first 10 rehabs
while I'm in there,
the hole, the crack cocaine was so strong.
I didn't know.
It still had that pull on me.
And it was still,
it was still-
it was like the puppet master.
So it was still pulling all the strings,
even while I was there just
trying to get my shit `together.
My life together, it
was pulling the strings.
It was running the show.
I didn't know that at the time,
'cause I had no idea.
Now, after about 15, 20 trips
and really putting forth that effort,
I start the soul searching.
I start centralization of some things.
Coming up from way deep inside, man,
that I haven't been
able to take a look at.
For the past...
say 30 years.
Imma say one thing.
And Imma end it on this note
because this is real personal to me.
My last program, man, my 30th one.
I was asleep
and something woke me up
and...
it was a dream
of my father
and me and my father smoking crack
in a mother-
In a garage, years ago, man.
And I think I was...
(sighs)
11 or 12
and...
It just came up all of a sudden
'cause I always wondered,
what was my first experiences?
What was my first experience on crack?
And with who?
And I thought of it was
with the neighborhood kids.
I thought my cousin.
My first experience with
crack cocaine was with my dad
and it took the 30th
motherfucking trip to rehab
for it to come up.
And I was thinking to myself,
I remember clearly now,
when it happened
and I remember after we were leaving,
we're leaving the garage.
We get into Corey.
He says, "Hey, don't, don't tell your mom.
Just don't say nothing
about this experience."
"Well, I got you pops, I'm good.
You know, hep, hep, hooray,
don't worry about nothin'."
But I remember this feeling
I had in my stomach, man.
It was because I wanted more
and I know I can't ask for no more.
"Hey, pops, can you give me?"
It was over, you know,
and he let me hit it,
I think about four times, man.
But as we were leaving,
that shit was only so tough.
I couldn't even tell him.
"Hey, pops and whatever this feeling is,
it's just, ah!
It's consuming me.
And I want more."
You know what?
After he dropped me back
off at my mother's house,
I buried that shit so motherfucking deep
that when I think I was 15 or 16
and that shit the neighborhood
and it came back around.
And I started doing the primos.
Thinking that was my first time.
Okay, this is it for me.
My first trial.
My first experience doing this shit.
Primos.
That wasn't it.
It was five years prior
to that with my father,
but I had buried that shit so deep.
It couldn't even come up
to show me how I felt way back then,
to stop me from moving
forward with the primos.
They kept me for 30 something
motherfucking years.
That one experience.
If I just could-
But it was so deep.
I buried that shit-
Man, if I would have died or
got hurt out there, you know,
but it took that shit
to the grave with me.
That's how deep it was, man.
And it's only one person,
I shared that with,
that shit hurt my mama, told my mama.
My first experience with that shit.
But look how many trips it took to rehab
for me to get to that place.
So,
it helps.
It helped me.
And it freed me
from this lie of the
first time I ever did it,
was with the primos, man,
in the neighborhood with the fellows.
That's a damn lie.
Man.
Now, moving forward,
all I have to do is keep
being open-minded to
these self-realizations.
Whenever they come, I don't give a fuck,
if it takes 20 more years
for something else to come up
that'll help me sit my feet
firmer on steady ground,
on solid ground, whatever it takes, man.
I don't care.
Whatever shit that I have
buried deep that I forgot about.
For the past thousand years
I'll let that shit come up,
so I can be set free a
little bit at a time.
So I could keep on putting one
foot in front of the other.
It wasn't never about the rehabs.
It was always about me,
having the courage,
having the strength,
having the fortitude,
the aptitude to really want
to put all the cards on the table.
Hell no!
Not in the beginning.
Took about 25 trips to rehab,
before I finally started to see
that it had to put something up,
in order to get something in return.
Fuck, I'm in rehab and I'm
going through the motions,
but I'm not really putting
forth the serious effort.
Then, I'm wondering why I ended back up
on the motherfucking side
of the freeway off-ramp.
It seemed like every time
I take a hit off the pipe,
load the smoke out,
I see prison boars (hand pounds on thigh),
somewhere in the smoke.
Two, three weeks, I'm in prison.
I'll leave rehab,
leave that motherfucker,
take a hit off the pipe,
blow the smoke off.
I see myself in the side
of some motherfucking freeway, y'all.
I'm way up there in San Fernando Valley,
off the fucking-
of the one-on-one freeway off of-
Oh.
Oh, my God, man, on the side
of the freeway off-ramp.
I said, "I can't believe this shit."
Now, I'm talking about three months later
after I left the rehab.
How the fuck they get way out here
on the side of a-
For real, for real, on the
side of the freeway off-ramp.
But that's what the smoke showed me,
from the hit from the pipe prior to that.
So I've got man-
I used to scare me to
take a hit off the pipe.
Once I left different rehabs,
because whatever I saw within
the midst of the smoke,
I knew that shit was coming true
and what not to do to stop it.
I couldn't change it.
And that's the power.
That be.
And that's what I was
under the grips under, man.
So,
(sighs)
I thank God for the rehabs.
I thank God for all the times
that I didn't have the courage, man,
but I just kept on going back.
That I just kept on going back
'cause even though I didn't
know what was going to happen.
I didn't know what I was to expect.
And even in the times that I knew
what I was getting into, man.
What I was going for.
Even if it was the wrong motives, man.
Then, at least, I knew that
I had a chance at something.
Maybe at love at the time, man.
When I met her, (hand pounds on thigh)
I never thought I can meet her.
We can come together and
live happily ever after.
That's what I thought at the
time over, it didn't work.
At least I had something
to believe in, you know,
it had something to bank on or to,
just for that moment, man.
To take them out of that,
the spirit of desperation,
the bullshit and everything else
that came with the
lifestyle of a crack head
of a cocaine addict.
And...
I'm not out the negative woods.
It's not over, not by far.
Wish it was, but it's not,
it's just putting one foot
in front of the other, man.
Doing the best I can with
what I'm working with.
And...
I tell you one thing (sighs),
I never gave up on me.
No matter what happens.
I'm going to solve, set, and down
where the smoke clears
and all of that bullshit.
Imma still keeping putting one
foot in front of the other.
Going for one for what I know.
Going for broke, man,
because it's all I know.
I wouldn't want it any
other motherfucking way.
Thank you.